you launched your own whiskey brand and
you were kind enough because we're
friends you sent me a bottle of your
brand of whiskey proper 12 Irish whiskey
and thank you for sending that to me I
brought your not here handy would you do
the honors sure sure I'll drink I'll
drink in your stead there yeah I think
well it's a really classy guest that
doesn't show up but sends booze yeah
we're gonna toast to you right now
Connor best I'm gonna toast witches as
well hang on oh you want a toast as well
wait [ __ ] you're three days away do it
biggest listen listen I'm two days away
from the biggest fight of my life so
I'll only drink after that's very good
we call it we call it ishka Baja in
Ireland
what ishka Baja translate to holy water
this is Irish holy water for you proper
number as well exactly that's what they
were talking about in the New Testament
yes
Connor is going to be facing off with a
khabib nurmagomedov at UFC 2 to 9 at
t-mobile Arena in Las Vegas on Saturday
October 6th order pay-per-view early you
do not want to miss this fight Conor
McGregor thank you so much for being
[Applause]
you